Somewhere in your city, right now, a
dispatcher is talking to a hundred radios
— on a frequency that didn't exist a
second ago and will be gone a second after
they stop.
Police, fire, transit, utilities —
hundreds of groups, sharing a handful of
channels, coordinated by one data stream
that never stops and never speaks.
Decode that one stream, and the entire
system opens up: every call announces
itself before it starts, and a single
software-defined radio can follow all of
it at once.
This is how trunked radio works — the
pool, the coordinator, the virtual
channels, the grants, and the two ways
calls share the air.
Five ideas, and by the end, you can read a
trunked system like a map.